- [Brian] Yes!
- [Kelly] I'm having one of those days
where all my words are coming out wrong.
- It's okay, it's okay.
- Okay, you have soft hands!
- Thank you, so do you!
I get to touch you this time.
- Oh yeah, we couldn't, yeah.
- We did a Skype last time.
- We can do this the
whole interview like this.
- It's so nice to be next to you.
- I know,
now we're able to embrace.
I like it.
- Kelly, this is legit!
(audience applauding)
- We're a real show.
This is season three.
This is solid wood.
- This is nice!
Like this is really nice.
I'm so happy.
- We're moving on up.
Season three, just saying.
But wait, so you're almost 40.
I'm 40-
You're 40 now, though, right?
- No, I turn 40 next Thursday.
- I turn 40 soon, too.
- Really?
- Yes.
- But you're a Taurus, though.
- Yes. You're an Aries?
- I'm an Aries.
It's Aries season by the way!
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience cheering)
That's my son.
- I just want the people to know that.
- My son is an Aries.
- When's his birthday?
- Through and through.
He's April 12th.
- [Brian] Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Brian] And yours is when?
- April 24th.
- Oh yeah,
you are, like, real Taurus.
- Yeah, no, like, real Taurus.
(Brian laughing)
- I'm like, "Oh!"
- All the good, all the bad.
- All the good.
Like just a bull
just going through.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That's how we got all this.
- That's how I got here.
- That's how we got this.
(Kelly laughs)
- I was like,
"I will push the damn door down."
- That's right. Ram it down.
Well, that's me.
- I'm excited, though.
Are you excited about 40?
I am.
- I am excited about it.
I know that it's like a major-
Like, to be 40-
It's so crazy because 40s like-
What are people saying?
40s like the new what?
30?
New 25?
- I don't know.
I feel like, in this industry-
- All y'all are laughing,
like nobody says that.
(everyone laughing)
But the thing is-
- I feel young cause this industry.
Everybody's always a different age.
- You're right.
- Like my whole life,
even in the industry,
I've been friends with people
that are much older than me
and much younger than me.
So it's just a weird industry.
- I will say that fiber
has become my best friend.
(Kelly laughs)
I was like,
what is this nonsense that I have to do?
I was like 40 must be like really-
I had a whole celebration
when my Squatty Potty came in the mail.
I was like, "Yes!"
- I love a Squatty Potty!
- It's like a revelation, right?
- My mom is gonna kill me.
So when my mom as a kid,
I would walk in, I'd be like,
"Why are your feet on the-"
We're short, right?
We just dangle everywhere.
We have no legs.
- Just feet dangling off the toilet?
- And so she always
had her feet prompt up.
And then I learned when I was pregnant,
that they had this thing
called this Squatty Potty
and I was like, "Get yourself one!"
- She's gonna get
everyone Squatty Potties.
- It's the most amazing invention.
- It's the best invention ever.
- It's literally just something you-
- I find that like getting older,
like 40, I find joy in random things
like going to Bed Bath & Beyond
is a different thing.
- Organizing.
- Returns are a different thing.
(audience laughs)
You know what I mean?
I was like, "This is really great."
- [Kelly] Your knees are different.
- Our knees are different, Kelly!
I was like,
"Oh, I'm not bending over to tie my shoes.
I'm gonna sit down and
bring my foot to me."
(Kelly and audience laughs)
It's just like, I'm not doing that.
But it's really fun
because now I feel like
I can just tell everybody,
"Well, I'm your elder."
- [Kelly] Yeah. Listen to me.
- People who are like 38,
I'm like, "I'm your elder."
So I'm like, "Shut up."
You know?
And I need to slow down on that.
But yeah, it's my birthday.
I'm excited.
I usually get a little nervous 'cause-
I mean, you all know how many days
in March there are, right?
How many days?
- [Kelly] What do you mean?
- [Brian] 31!
So, thank you.
Most of my friends-
The knuckles, Kelly!
So most of the people,
most of my friends never remember
that there's 31 days in March.
So I always get my birthday gifts
a day early or a day late
and a day late is April Fools.
- Oh.
- So they always give me
pranks or trash gifts.
- They're not good friends.
- I'm not trying to be mean to my friends.
I'm really not.
But like, y'all know what y'all do.
But yeah.
So I'm always trying to make sure
people remember there's 31 days in March.
And no one ever,
including my family,
they're calling March 30th
and I'm like, "That's early."
Or they'll forget.
But-
(audience laughs)
- And you're like, "Fine."
- [Brian] Yeah. Fine. Cool.
- No, the knuckle thing.
- Yes, the knuckles.
Do you also know the knuckles for,
what is it?
Do you know the nine times tables?
- Wait, what?
- Okay.
So like to give like-
Yeah, you know, nine times tables.
So if I wanted to do nine times five,
you go 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
45.
See 4,
5.
Nine times seven.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7
is 63.
- Why didn't no one tell me this
when I was a kid?
See, it's not helping you.
- Because I'm old!
I'm 40!
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- I don't have to do that anymore.
- You don't have to do that anymore.
Who uses multiplication?
- Phone a friend for your homework.
- That's what's gonna be a problem,
I'm just gonna start saying things like,
"Who needs a wallet? I'm 40.
Who needs ice? I'm 40.
Me, I need ice.
'Cause I'm 40."
But yeah.
(audience applauds)
- You're back for season
3 of Atlanta on FX.
So you took years off between seasons.
- Yeah. We took a while.
We took a while.
- Was it weird to jump
back into character?
- I was terrified because
the way we left Alfred in season 2
was in Robbin season, you know?
So we had him running through woods,
being shot at, we had him going
to all different kind of crazy things.
And so, I, Brian,
know that I had changed a lot.
I had done a lot of growing up,
I guess you should say.
And I was like,
"Well, where's Alfred now?"
This is literally almost
four years in the making.
And I just realized,
I was like,
"Well, just lean in.
Wherever you are that's where Alfred is."
Except that he's in Europe now.
I was like, they dropped you in Europe.
So it was an incredible experience
because at this time
we were filming during the lockdown.
- [Kelly] Yeah, which
is lucky to get to work-
- It was amazing because
the last thing they should have done
is let our black asses
run around in Europe
(audience laughs)
because we had the time of our lives.
Like it really welcoming
and really amazing.
Like it was just so calm and serene
and then the four of us
were more together this season.
Because we were the only people there
that we could depend on in that way-
- In your bubble.
- In our bubble.
So we were together a lot.
We celebrated my birthday there.
Donald threw me a tattoo party,
which was really nice.
- Oh wait, was that a good decision
or a bad decision?
- It was my decision!
That's all that matters.
Like we're all getting tattoos so-
- You're gonna love it!
- And we all got matching
Atlanta A tattoos.
- Oh, I like it!
- Not Zazie, though.
She was like, "I'm not playing that game."
But we all got matching tattoos.
It was really great.
This season's unlike anything
we've ever done before.
- Where were you in Europe?
- We were in London, for the most part.
And then we were in Amsterdam
and then we did a little
bit of time in Paris.
So there were certain buildings
and museums and stuff
that we could just run rampant in
because nobody was there
and they were like, "Yeah, sure. Go."
And I was like,
"Oh, this is really, really great."
- Kind of cool 'cause-
- It was unbelievable.
It was unbelievable.
Yeah. It wouldn't have been the case.
It was great.
- So you went to school in Atlanta, right?
- I did go to school in Atlanta.
I went to Morehouse College.
- Morehouse College. All right.
You like going there?
You like living there?
- I like going there
but let me tell you something.
I hate it.
I was a (beep) in college.
I have to say it.
That's what I was.
I really was.
That's the only way I could put it.
I was very much an activist.
I feel like I was in one
of those 1980s movies
where the Dean calls you in and is like,
"What are you rebel against today, Henry?"
And I'm like, "What do you got?"
- Just say something.
- Just tell me what it is!
and that's who I was.
- You were on a mission.
- I was on a mission.
I was like,
this is the only all black male college
in the country.
You know?
Like you've got all these young black men
coming from all different
parts of the country.
From the world, really.
And we're in higher education.
in Atlanta, Georgia.
And I was like, "I wanna rebel."
So I grew my hair out.
You know what I mean?
I got my ears pierced.
I had tattoos.
I would wear-
I was insane.
- I feel like this is
what people do in college?
- You would think so
but Morehouse is very much,
it's prestigious.
It's like, you wear suits
and you're supposed to be
an upstanding young
black man in the country.
And my ass was just
running around this campus
just doing stupid stuff!
Like I was doing stupid stuff!
I'm really grateful
that I'm a notable alumni now
and I hope it stays that way
but I was trash.
(everyone laughs)
- I love you so much.
- But I had a great time.
I still have the same
friends from college.
I ran the streets of Atlanta back then.
So it's like-
- You're very self aware,
that amazing.
- [Brian] I had to be!
'Cause I was a mess!
I was a mess.
I was a mess at college.
- I think we all were messes.
Especially was in our early 20s.
- [Brian] This was
different though, Kelly.
This was-
This guy was-
This was different.
- [Kelly] Oh man.
I kind of wish I could have met him.
- Oh, man.
He's 40 now.
(audience laughs)
I can't.
- Okay. Wait.
I don't wanna not talk about this
'cause you've also got a crime movie
with Brad Pitt.
- Yeah.
- So it's out this summer?
- So what's that about?
- You know,
I've always had a dream
of being in an action movie
where you get all the explosions
and the slow motion walk,
you know what I mean?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I gotta do it
and I gotta do it with Brad Pitt.
And I was like, "I know you lying."
Yeah.
And I got to be blonde.
I was like,
"Yes! I get to be blonde-"
- So you're still rebelling.
- I'm still rebelling!
(everyone laughs)
That is literally kind what
my hair look like in college.
And I was like,
"Oh, that's a little too close to home."
But yeah,
it's a great, great
film called Bullet Train
directed by David Leitch who did like,
you know,
Atomic Blonde and Deadpool.
And we did this in the
middle of the quarantine.
So like in October-
- But you worked all in quarantine?
That's cool.
- I'm insane.
I told you I was a rebel.
- I work too.
I never stopped either.
- I know!
- It was a nice distraction.
- I feel like I need
to be interviewing you
so you can have a break.
- Trust me. I'm tired.
I'm gonna have a weekend.
- Don't switch.
- It's kind of nice though,
because I don't feel
like I was affected during quarantine
like everybody else was, in that sense.
Because I had to still keep going
so there was no time to process.
- It was the same with Bullet Train.
We filmed on Sony.
They built a train.
Like they built cars of the train.
There was a huge screen
with moving pictures going.
I felt like it was very classic Hollywood
like back in the 20s
when there was like 30 people moving a set
and turning this.
You had to get back to the bare minimum.
But yeah, it's a huge action movie.
The cast is insane.
And I got to fight Brad Pitt.
Like I get to kick Brad Pitt's ass.
(everyone laughs)
And it was kind of great because,
I mean,
this man was the happiest he had ever been
and also,
we have a lot of fights together
and there's one particular time
that we're fighting
and I got him in a chokehold
and like they would yell, "Cut"
and he would just laying my arms.
And I was like, "Oh."
I was like,
"How is it possible that
I feel safer with you
lying in my arms?"
And it's like, 'cause it's Brad Pitt.
- [Kelly] I love you right now.
- Yeah, it was great.
Like all of us,
Aaron Taylor-Johnson, Joey king,
we all just signed up to have a great time
and just be bloody and
kick each other's butts-
- What a fun job.
- It was the best.
It didn't feel real.
It really didn't feel real,
but it was really great.
And it's gonna be an amazing movie.
- I'm excited.
I love action films.
- Yeah, me too.
- [Kelly] I love them.